as the white house tracks tens of
thousands of illegal migrants now headed
for the united states key members of the
biden administration just met with their
mexican counterparts about the ongoing
border crisis however the border czar
vice president kamala harris was not
among them the vp was at a new jersey
bakery instead look i live in jersey the
suites are fabulous honey but get to the
border there's a crisis brian
a couple of things uh it's amazing i've
never had someone
ever in my life seen someone get
assigned a job and have no interest in
doing it a couple of zoom calls one
visit goes to the border goes in and out
of sedentary way the only thing she
commented on was when the horse
situation she thought there was a
controversy she immediately ran to a
camera and ran in and said well this is
a problem with the way uh certain border
patrol members are treating uh haitian
immigrants it turns out the
investigation is still ongoing because
there's nothing there there's what you
need with kamala harris well she likened
it to slavery didn't she yeah she was
unbelievable and all she needs to do
guys is not solve the problem try try to
solve the problem meet with the people
demand answers if she has that charm if
she's got that stealiness to her she
could start getting answers and look
like a hero in this situation just by
putting the effort in she doesn't put
the effort in which is no excuse for and
it's happening over and over again
wow that's really sad morgan i mean
actually our standard should be higher
than that as the american people it
shouldn't just be about the effort you
should actually be effective because the
president has given you that task
basically nobody else in his office is
doing it parts of his administration are
trying but he gave it to her so trying i
don't know brian i think she's got to do
better than try i'd like to first steps
baby steps baby steps okay but she's the
vice president
baby okay morgan
you know it's interesting because so
everything that the president or the
vice president does it's all about
imagery right and we always see uh the
president and his beloved ice cream i
like ice cream too i don't blame him now
we see the vice president at bakery's as
an aside whatever happened to the apples
that were in the obama white house when
we were all supposed to be healthier
anyway i digress but it does sort of
have this uh let them eat cake feeling
doesn't it whenever we're all going to
the grocery store and we're paying you
know a lot more for each bag than we
paid a year ago when gases pie uh when
there's worker shortages and you i just
i guess from a comms perspective i i
don't understand why the white house has
the president eating ice cream and the
vice president eating bakeries and
sweets it just all seems i think it's
indicative actually of how out of touch
they all are let everybody eat cake yeah
reminds me of nancy pelosi in the heart
of the panda right people dying by the
thousands every single day and look
we're still losing good people it was so
much worse then and we got a really good
look and i like talented ice cream it's
a little pricey but remember she was
eating i mean it is it's kind of the
epitome of out of touch really you're
going to put that up in social media you
know i do want to get into the
nitty-gritty because you you both were
having such a reaction
to what is going on here what are your
thoughts because you've lived in
california under these lawmakers you
know this is someone kamal harris who
campaigned on and assured us that she
was competent and she was experienced
she campaigned in part on the need for
reformed immigration laws that she as a
woman of color would champion for the
rights and the humanity of those people
of color who are trying to come across
our border she said and now she's
missing and to brian's point i agree
with what he said however that if she
would just show up really that she could
then have measurable impacts that we
could take because we all know it's a
far more well how does she do when she
was in california because if she's going
to show up and she doesn't succeed i
don't think that's enough i really feel
strongly about that you got to perform i
hear what you're saying i just what i
mean to highlight is the fact that it's
an incredibly complex situation that
would likely never be solved within one
administration and the fact that mexico
is our greatest ally in securing the
southern border and she didn't even show
up this last time speaks volumes to me
who she continues leaving behind and
it's everyone that she purports to
represent kennedy two things here one
she has hired crisis communications
people because uh when she laughs
inappropriately uh some of the things
she does comes off is very unserious and
very unlikable so maybe in her mind
she's like let me talk to kids let me go
to bakeries because people love kids and
they love bakeries so if i'm around
those two things people will like me
that is not really doing the job that a
vice president is supposed to do jim
jordan always looks busy because he
never wears a sport coat i don't even
think he owns one but it always looks
like he's ready to get in the ring no
matter what that's what she needs to do
she needs to be she needs to drop those
she needs to do two things yes she needs
to either go to mexico and the border
and you know all of the cities that are
plagued by this cruel inhumane
immigration broken system she needs to
all the way to indiana montana she needs
to go to congress constantly and be
talking to them about legislation so
either she is advocating her
responsibility or this is the the
biggest pile of sexist claptrap and the
administration does not take her
seriously and they are plugging in to
her into bakeries and nurseries it's
such a great point so we were talking
about pink and blue colors earlier what
you're talking about is this is just
another way of saying that this is a
woman with the job and she doesn't have
to be hard about things she doesn't have
to do the difficult part i mean that's
what it sounds like yeah be busy go do
the stuff well look i have likened it to
um
that friend that you have that's always
on their phone and you know they're
always on their phone because all you
see is the top of their head yet when
you call them and you say there's a
crisis they don't pick up they ghost you
that's what this feels like right now
with the vice president she's ghosting
us
not okay we fire that friend don't we i
don't know i'm just using an analogy if
you don't have a friend like that i went
on brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now